coming to the table and negotiating a
piece whether it's Donald Trump whether
it's Biden whether it's anybody what do
you think it takes uh do you think it's
possible uh and if you're in a room if
jerro Krishner is in the room with
Vladimir Putin and Vladimir zalinski
what does it take to have a productive
conversation and what does it take for
that conversation to fail like what are
the trajectories that lead to success
and failure I think we go back to
negotiations number one is trust right
both leaders have to have the ability to
communicate what an offramp is without
fearing it's going to leak to the public
so if you go to the posture of zalinski
right now and by the way president
zalinsky I have a lot of respect for the
courage he showed uh especially
initially um you know you saw what gani
did in Afghanistan they they were
getting attacked by the Taliban he took
the cash and got the hell out of there
staying in Kiev when he did how he did
it was one of the most Brave things
we've seen in a long time uh and he has
a ton of my respect and admiration for
doing that but now he's promising his
people we're going to win the war and
the military action has not necessarily
coincided with that sentiment and so
there has to be some form of of off-ramp
but he can't say that publicly so for
him to be able to work privately with
somebody who can help create a new
paradigm where both leaders can say
we're going to stop the Bloodshed we're
going to stop the risk of nuclear war
for the world we're going to stop um
what's
happening that's really what it will
take how that occurs again it's not
something I'm involved in now so I don't
know who the right broker is or how to
put that together but essentially they
need somebody in between them who can
figure out how do you create a landing
Zone that that works because neither
part is going to jump until the pool is
filled with water and you have to
outline what the go forward looks like
because you can't just stop it for then
it to get worse for both parties you
have to you have to move it forward into
what happens next that hopefully can
start to turn the tide to benefit both
sides where they can focus on the future
instead of being stuck into the old
Paradigm of who started what who's to
blame for what who did what to who it's
just a lot of tough stuff now that
that's occurred that's going to be hard
to walk back
and um it's a big task to get it done
but for the sake of the world it'd be
amazing if we were able to reach a
conclusion to that conflict just going
back to the your earlier mention of
North
Korea what do you think it takes to
bring Vladimir Putin and Vladimir
zalinsky to the table together
leadership so you you you're saying like
it has to be a US
president it has to be somebody who's
willing to put themsel on the line yeah
to go and do it and you know again if
you're the US president and you're the
most powerful nation in the world you
should be trying but I do think again
the posture that the US has taken has
probably been in a place where they it
would be very hard for them to get the
trust of Russia based on the way that
they've played their moves to date you
know I always thought from the beginning
that Putin would try to bring in
president X and China to resolve it to
basically give a big screw you to
America to say you know China's now the
one you know in charge of this but that
hasn't seemed to manifest itself to date
either but it takes leadership you know
the leaders have to get it and say you
know let's get everyone together and
let's try to get this done because every
day it goes on a more people are dying
um and B you know we do risk nuclear war
for the world which is not a good
situation